المترجم: Amna Omar
المدقّق: Ghalia Turki
لقد كان تائهاً وربما مازال كذلك إلى الآن.
لكن بدأت تتضح بعض الأشياء.
كان يسأل نفسه دائماً،
من أنا وماذا أفعل هنا؟
لماذا خلقني الله؟
وكان أكثر سؤال يؤلمه:
ما أنا؟
ماذا أعني للناس؟
هل يحبونني؟
أم يكرهونني؟
و لهذا، كان يعمل على إرضائهم دائماً.
كان يرسم البهجة على وجوههم أحيانًا،
وأحيانًا أخرى يحاول كسب إحترامهم وإعجابهم.
لكن، كل المحاولات كانت تنهي بالفشل.
"كلاكيت" أول مرة، حاول أن يكون
الإنسان المشاغب.
فيطرد في كل حصة دراسات إجتماعية خارج
الصف، لأنه كان يسخر من كل شيء يقوله أستاذه
مثل "القلعة"
كان يختبئ خلف الباب ويُفزِع زميلاته
ويضرب أصدقائه ببعض المطاط والورق
لكنه فشل أيضًا !
انتقل إلى مدرسة أخرى بعد ان تم تغيير
محل إقامته ليعيش مع عائلته في مكان آخر.
لذا قرر أن يستغل هذه الفرصه لإصلاح
نظرة الناس له.
انتقل للعيش وسط أشخاص جدد لا يعرفونه
لذلك سيحاول ان ينال إعجابهم بأي طريقة.
قرر أن يصبح "الطالب المجتهد"
اجتهد في دراسته وحصل على درجات عالية،
لكنه فشل مرة أخرى!
السبب كان انتقال قافلة صومالية إلى مدرسته
في هذا العام الدراسي.
و كانت جميع الفصول تسخر من هؤلاء الطلاب
بسبب اختلاف لون بشرتهم
لم يكن راضيًا عما يفعلونه
و رأى أن أفعالهم تلك خاطئة.
قرر أن يدافع عنهم وبالفعل قد فعل ذلك!
وخسر في سبيل ذلك جميع الأشخاص
الذي كان يسعى إلى إرضائهم.
ولم يستطيع تعويض ذلك بالإجتهاد الدراسي.
فقرر هو و أخاه أن يخبروا والديهم
برغبتهم في العودة الي مدرستهم القديمة
وبالفعل أخبروهم
وافقوا بشرط أن يتفوقوا في الدراسة
و بالفعل أحرز درجات مرتفعة،
وعاد إلى مدرسته القديمة
كان يوجد بهذه المدرسة جميع أصدقائه القدامى
و الذين فشل في التقرب منهم.
و اتضح انهم يكِنُّون له كل الحب والتقدير،
ولكنه لم يعلم ذلك.
عاد إلى حب الطفولة
وهي إحدى زميلاته بالمدرسة
و قرر أنه بمجرد أن يلتقي بها
سوف يفصح لها عن حبه مهما كلفه الأمر.
و بالفعل..
عاد إلى المدرسة
حتى أنه إكتشف في طريقه أثناء عودته
قدرته على كتابة الشعر
لذلك قرر أن يستغل هذه الموهبة
للحصول على حبها
محاولات بائسة ...
بدأ يستمع إلى أغاني كاظم الساهر
و يقرأ للشاعر نزار قباني
ثم يقوم بتقليدهم في أقوالهم وبنفس الكيفية
و لكن كل هذا لم يفلح معها.
كان محطم للغاية آنذاك ،
لم يكن يدري ماذا يفعل؟
أعتقد أن الحياة توقفت بالنسبة له.
مرَّ هذا العام وبدأ الدراسة الثانوية.
واقترحت عليه زميلته أن
يقدم كتاباته للنشر في مجلة ما.
و بالفعل قدمها إلى المجلة.
و بعد فترة قصيرة
وصله الرد منهم وكان فحواه:
"من الممكن أن تنشر في أحد الأعداد
القادمة" (كانت مجلة شهرية)
لذلك قرر عدم التخلي عن هذا الحلم
حيث شعر للمرة الأولى في حياته
أنه يفعل ما يريده
وليس ما يريده غيره لإرضائهم.
و بالفعل قام بمراسلتهم بشكل دوري
كل أسبوع أو أسبوعين
ليستفسر عن سؤال واحد مُكرر
"متى سوف تقومون بنشر كتاباتي؟"
استمر على هذا الحال أربعة أشهر
حتى نشرت أول قصيدة له
في شهر يوليو عام 2010
بعدما قرر ألا يتخلى عن حلمه،
أرسل لهم العديد مما كتب.
حضر معهم أول اجتماع
في فبراير عام 2011
وجد العديد منهم في سن مقارب له
ومنهم من كان أصغر أو أكبر منه سنًا أيضًا
مرت سنواتٍ طوال
وأصبح يكتسب العديد من الصداقات في المجلة.
كانوا يكِنُّون له كل إحترام و تقدير،
و لكن لم يلاحظ ذلك.
لأنه لم يكن يكترث لذلك.
كان عاكفًا على صقل مهارة الكتابة لديه.
كان يحاول استغلالها بأية طريقة.
ثم التحق بالجامعة ،
وانضم إلى إحدى المنظمات العالمية للشباب.
كان أحد أحلامه الانضمام إليها.
كان يحلم بذلك حيث اعتقد
أنها يمكن أن تُحدِث تغييراً في شخصيته.
كان لا يزال متمسكاً بهذا السراب.
بعد ما أنضم إليها في أحد المؤتمرات
التي أقيمت لشرح آلية المنظمة
أعطوا كل شخص ظرفاً
وطلبوا منهم كتابة أحلامهم
الذين يريدون تحقيقها في ال 5 سنوات القادمة
و بالفعل قام بكتابة جميع أحلامه.
لقد نحت كل هذه الأحلام التي كتبها في عقله
ولم ينسَ منها أي حلم.
وبعد أربعة أو ستة أشهر تقريباً
عَلِم أن المجلة التي اجتهد فيها
و بنى عليها احلام كثيرة جداً
على أساس بقائها
سوف تُغلق أبوابها للأبد
كان مصدوماً ولم يكن يدري ماذا يفعل!
ماذا أفعل الآن بكل هذه الأحلام
التي بنيتها على أساس بقاء هذه المجلة
إلى أين سوف تذهب؟
وعلى أي اساس سوف أبني
أحلام جديدة لي؟
و لكنه أدرك شيئاً وقتها.
لاحظ أن كل السنوات التي قضاها
بمحاولة إرضاء الناس،
لم يكن مصيبًا فيها.
أدرك بأن فكرته حول الأشخاص الناجحين
أنهم هم فقط الأشخاص الإجتماعيين خاطئة.
كان مخطئاً عندما ظن أن الأشخاص الإنطوائيين
سوف يعيشون ويموتون وحيدين.
لم تكن كل هذه الأشياء إلا مجرد أفكار
ترسخت بداخله منذ صغره وحتى تقدم بالعمر.
بل وأثرَّت عليه بشكل سلبي
حتى أنه لم يكن باستطاعته النوم أحيانًا.
كان من أحد أحلامه أن يُصبح
رئيس قسم الكتابة الشعرية بالمجلة وقد حققه!
وكتب حلماً آخر بأن يكون
جزءً من هذه المنظمة وقد حققه.
بقي فيها 5 أشهر ورغم أنه لم يستعد الظرف
إلا أنه لم ينسى ما كتبه فيه.
حلم أن يجد تعليقات إيجابية من الناس
على مواقع التواصل الإجتماعي للمجلة ،
ووجد بالفعل ردود فعل إيجابيه تجاه ما يكتب
وعبر الناس أنهم يريدون قراءة المزيد له.
كان سعيدًا للغاية.
كان يحلم بأن يقف على هذا المسرح
في يومٍ كهذا وها هو!
(تصفيق)
كانت كل هذه الأحلام التي حققها مجرد
أهداف تم تحقيقها في سبيل تحقيق أكبر أحلامه
وهو أن يؤثر في حياة
أكبر عدد من الناس من خلال كتاباته.
لا تخافوا، أنتم لستم وحيدين في هذا العالم.
الفكرة والخوف منها هو ما يوصلكم إلى الوحدة
إخرجوا، وتأملوا،
وقومو التجارب.
احلموا !
شكراً لكم.
(تصفيق)